joining us right now live on the phone
exclusive interviews in the white house
tonight president donald trump mr
president thank you for being with us
well thank you they did a very good job
i will say
okay they get good grades um let me go
to the woodward book
um i was first surprised that you spoke
to him
i don't think a lot of good comes from
talking to bob woodward my own personal
opinion
but let's go to the things that karl
rove was pointing out that biden said
today
ten days after the first identified case
10 days you put the travel ban in effect
and it was a subsequent ban the first
quarantine in over 15
50 years he said it was hysterical
xenophobia
and fear-mongering on your part
two and a half months later he reversed
himself at least according to a campaign
ad
why what do you believe that one
decision at ten days after the first
case in america
what impact did that have and what were
you saying to bob woodward
well first of all on the woodward book
on the book itself
he called he i didn't participate in his
last one and he does hit jobs with
everybody he even did it on obama
constant hit jobs on bush i guess they
did three books they were all terrible
so i figured you know
let's just give it a little shot i'll
speak to him it wasn't a big deal i
speak to him
and let's see i don't know if the book
is good or bad i have no idea
probably almost definitely won't read it
because i don't have time to read it
but uh i gave it a little bit of a shot
sounds like it's not going to be good
but if you look at what i said today i
said don't panic
we don't want to be jumping up and down
and going wild don't panic
i'm a cheerleader for this country and i
don't want to see panic
and uh i thought what matt said was
fantastic because we would have lost two
million two and a half million lives
instead of the number we're talking
about anything above one is no good
it's no good we can't have it it was
china's fault
they sent this to us and it's no good
but uh
i thought i'd give the bob woodward some
time i gave him some time
but as usual with the the books he
writes that didn't work out too well
perhaps i don't know maybe it was maybe
it's good who knows
but as far as the the timing is
concerned i did something very important
as you know at the end of january i
banned i banned china because the people
from china because they were heavily
infected
and i had a lot of people including dr
fauci and i don't say that with
disrespect it's really what he believed
but a lot of people believe that
that we shouldn't ban them it was no
reason to ban them and biden was going
around for
many many weeks after that saying it's
not even going to be a problem you
covered it
incredibly actually karl rove covered
that incredibly tonight
and uh just incredibly actually and
they were all going around no problem no
problem everybody practically everybody
nobody had any idea it would be as
violent as it turned out to be and
we studied it we understand it now we're
opening up
but we could have lost two million two
and a half million maybe even more than
that if we did it a different way and
we've done a really good job and if you
look at our numbers our fatality numbers
compared to other
countries we're in we're in really i
mean it's amazing what we've done
we've been able to do something that a
country especially with the kind of size
we're dealing with
we've done an incredible job i watched
your
your press conference today in the and
the the general tone of the questioning
was that
you misled the country because you told
bob woodward on february 7th
uh this looks like it's going to be five
times as
as bad as a normal flu virus i think
most americans may not even know
that there are years with the influenza
virus that we lose tens of thousands of
americans
uh it's not uncommon and
but your actions just seven days earlier
were
you put a travel ban in effect and the
quarantine in effect again hasn't been
done in 50 years
so actions mean something and you
taking it seriously was very clear then
and then when you said well i don't want
people to panic
they say well you must have been
downplaying it wouldn't your actions
contradict that narrative
yeah absolutely and if you look at we've
had flu years where we lost
70 80 and 90 000 people people don't
realize that
but if you look that and multiply that
times five it's actually more
than we lost that we could have lost two
million two and a half million as matt
said if we did it a different way
but uh what i wanna show is i wanna show
a calmness i'm the leader of the country
i can't be jumping up and down and
scaring people i don't wanna scare
people i want people not to panic
and that's exactly what i did and if you
look at the
representatives of joe biden you see
what they were saying they said no
problem this won't be a problem he
didn't think it was going to be a
problem until
months later he was way late pelosi was
way way late
and i was at the end of january far
ahead of everybody because i did
something nobody wanted me to do
nobody wanted me to do the ban on china
and then as you know shortly thereafter
i did a ban on europe
that was frankly even more controversial
and that was good because i saw what was
going on in italy
and in spain and in france and we did a
band there and if we didn't do those
bans we would have had numbers that were
much much more and if we didn't do the
shutdown and now the reopening
and they should do the opening faster if
you look at some of the states like
north carolina pennsylvania you look at
what they're doing they're taking so
they're shut down they're still shut
down michigan is terrible it's still
shut down
and that's a shame it's a shame they
don't know what they're doing frankly
but they should all be open and our
country is doing very well we have
record numbers of jobs you saw the
numbers just came out for the four
months it's the
largest number ever by far not even
close
and retail sales the same thing there
it's record numbers so
we're opening up with a strong v not
just a v it's a very strong v
and we're gonna have a tremendous year
next year we're going to have a very
good quarter
and that's going to be announced before
the election
but there's there's voting going on now
you see joe biden he makes very few
appearances
the the media seems to be willing to i
don't think he's answered a hundred
questions since march
uh you know you've answered a couple of
thousand plus questions in in that
period of time
uh do you think the media is giving him
a pass do you see
uh look everybody that i meet that i run
into
everywhere and even people in the media
interestingly
quietly and democrats i know quietly are
saying
joe looks like he is weak and he is
frail how do you interpret joe biden
the basement bunker strategy his
unwillingness to take questions
well the media in terms of what they're
doing is actually worse than what you're
saying because it looks to me like
they're asking him a question and then
he's reading an answer off the
teleprompter now that would mean that
like your friend over there donna
brazile uh he has
who fox brilliantly hired
he sounds like your favorite host donna
brazile that's another
real great one but it would look to me
like he's been
given the questions and he's reading the
answers but
that would mean that the media is giving
him the questions they never gave me the
questions i can tell you that it's like
we have some pretty wild times but they
uh they hit me with the worst
possible questions possible and you have
to
learn to do it and you have to be able
to do it and if you can't do it you
can't be a politician you certainly
can't represent
our country because when you deal with
president xi
and putin and kim jong-un and all of the
people you have to deal with
in all due respect to the media they're
much tougher they're much smarter
than the people i have to deal with in
the in the various rooms and outside by
the helicopters and all the places i'm
willing always to take questions but
i don't get i don't get any help in
terms of here's the question and
you can read an answer to it i've never
seen anything like it and
frankly i think the media is disgracing
themselves but
it's obvious that joe is reading the
answers off a teleprompter in many cases
that happened yesterday when he said
move it closer a woman
move it down i think is what it's closer
meaning move the teleprompter closer
it's terrible it's actually terrible